all right everyone good afternoon and
welcome to the 2013 GE sustainability
leaders series my name is Stuart dequeue
I'm the program director at the Yale
Center for business the environment
thank you for coming people are gonna be
filtering in grabbing lunch welcome to
our online audience on the Yale YouTube
channel this talk as I said is brought
to you by the Yale Center for business
and the environment in partnership with
the GE foundation and we broke movie
broadcast simultaneously through the
Yale YouTube channel the sustainability
leaders series brings thought leaders to
campus to speak and engage with students
and faculty about the challenges and
opportunities for implementing
sustainability within their respective
organizations today we are quite pleased
to welcome Gary Lawrence vice president
and chief sustainability officer of a
calm for a conversation with Professor
Paul and ask asan big questions for a
better built environment we'll have
about 30 minutes facilitated discussion
between Paul and Gary and then we'll be
taking questions from the audience a
brief introduction about Paul Paul is
the Teresa and H John Hines professor
and practice of chemistry and the
environment for the environment and the
director of the Center for green
chemistry and green engineering at Yale
dr. Anastos has published widely on
topics and science through
sustainability including 11 books such
as benign by design designing safer
polymers Green engineering and his
seminal work with co-author John Warner
green chemistry theory and practice in
addition Paul is a collaborator a friend
someone who is pushing folks both in
academia the student population people
in the private sector to figure out new
ways of collaborating and coming
together so he's the perfect person to
facilitate a discussion of this type
welcome to Paul and Gary and I'll hand
it over to Paul Thank You Stuart
first of all let me say congratulations
to the Center for business in the
environment because this program is
exactly the type of thing that we need
to be to be doing more of and focusing
on and it's quite a quite a tribute to C
day that that this program is
as successful as as it is and marking
that and I should say personifying that
is our as our guest today Gary Lawrence
when we talk about thought leaders in
the area of sustainability leaders and
positions of major influence and impact
gary lawrence does does personify that
so we're very lucky too
so Gary as as Stewart mentioned is the
vice president and chief sustainability
officer for AECOM a comm is an eight
billion dollar global corporation that
provides professional and technical
management support services across a
wide range of sectors with over 45,000
employees worldwide architects engineers
designers planners scientists and on so
it really has the the big perspective on
on what is necessary in order to think
about not only where we are in terms of
infrastructure today but where we need
to to go in the future as everybody in
this room of course knows the
infrastructure that we build today is
going to be around for quite a long time
and have a have an impact for a long
time so so gary has a very diverse
background everything from from teaching
at the University of Washington on the
Faculty of the University of Washington
to be the director of planning for the
City of Seattle and has been with as
well as leading smaller enterprises in
the in the area of sustainability and
has been with a cobbler how many years
for three years so what I'd like to just
start off with is sort of a an
overarching question of could you tell
us a little bit about a
it's a it's global mission but even more
important bringing it down to how it
looks to advance sustainability protect
and build in ways to increase
sustainability its mission statements
sometimes actually we pretty much live
that focus on our obligation to make
money for our shareholders while
improving conditions for human
development around the world so we talk
about sustainability for instance not as
a green idea the framework for mastering
complexity and mastering complexity in
ways that improve value and reduce risk
so the company is actually being built
to manage complexity bending better than
any other organization on the planet and
it's not all complexity but we touch
every aspect of development and human
habitation so it's those systems and the
connective tissue between the center's
so what are some of the big types of
focus errors I I'm hearing architecture
water systems and give us a flavor for
some of those places where any comm
plays I know it's probably tougher to
say where it doesn't play whole cities
first new cities brings together all of
our disciplines and I have to
a calm is all about interdisciplinarity
we know that there are some issues where
we have to go very deep and get highly
technical but if we do that in a way
that we we're not always thinking about
how this connects to that we can't
actually serve our clients and help them
so city city making is one thing we do
we're in a joint venture as the
designers and the construction managers
for the new 2nd Avenue subway in New
York where the designers we were the
designers for the alumni Olympics and
we're the designers for the Rio Olympics
we work on things like transportation
systems high-speed rail systems as one
of the participants in high-speed rail
consortium all over the world so again
we we've grown from a collection of
companies about 20 years ago there were
26 companies into a much bigger group
some of our competitors refer to us as
the Borg because most of our growth from
from 15,000 to now forty-seven thousand
eight hundred I checked the numbers on
the train coming up and evidently we
acquired something but all that growth
is really focused on this notion that we
only make money if our clients are
successful and our clients need help in
understanding how one thing relates to
another so they can leverage their
investments and gain advantage so the
the scale is is daunting you work on
when you think about the the mega trends
whether it's climate change whether it's
resource depletion whether it's rapid
urbanization can these mega trends and
do these mega trends
affect strategic decision-making at a
fortune 500 company like a they affect
our strategy in a couple of ways first
of all we have clients that are really
worried about in certain aspects of
change and they will come in and push us
to get better at helping them be
successful in that change environment
and then sometimes we actually have to
be ahead of our clients so I'm on a
number of committees around the world
and one of them is the world economics
forums climate change Council there were
thinking about adaptation and resilience
and how it relates to security and human
and human populations around the world
so the the energy water waste and food
Nexus and how those things react to one
another so that we can be thought
leaders and helping our clients again
figure out where they ought to be
rethinking their approach changing their
questions that because we find within
the company and out doing business that
unless you've gotten the question right
it's impossible to come up with anything
that works and I know that in my past I
have created really magnificent
disasters by going out to solve a
problem and finding out later it was
only an attribute of the issue rather
than a fundamental part of it so if
there's anything I could say to you be
really careful about fundamentals in
attributes because if you're just
dealing with the attributes you're gonna
be wasting a lot of your time won't get
at the problem and I just want to say
for those of you that are in my class I
didn't make him say that
so are there are there certain
principles or frameworks that you use to
to drive or promote resource efficiency
in across supply chains and things for
your clients yeah we have three roles in
the company and one of my roles is the
efficiency of a comm as an enterprise
you know we have offices in 130
countries and so getting at this notion
of a supply chain is difficult we're
doing things like increasing our
investments in telepresence which is a
brand of communication tool where it's
like you're sitting right across the
table from someone even though they
might be three or four thousand miles
away because we find that a single
telepresence room equates to about 11
international business class round round
trips so if we can reduce the amount of
flying we do we reduce the amount of
kerosene that's being burned at high
altitudes and and that and we're also
increasing the efficiency and improving
the work/life balance of our employees
because when you get to be my age travel
is no longer interesting nor fun
I had a meeting with the Minister of the
Environment for Singapore you know and
it's a 19-hour direct flight from New
York for a four-hour meeting and a
19-hour flight back made no
environmental sense critically important
client to us and and telepresence
wouldn't have worked for that but there
are a number of other things
particularly within the organisation
where we can do that we are dramatically
reducing the amount greenhouse gases in
our own supply chain that's for two
reasons first of all it's the right
thing to do and it's going to reduce our
costs
the second is that in order for us to be
a supplier to firms like shell or
anybody in the oil gas business to be
part of their supply chain you have to
demonstrate you are the continuous
improvement program in terms of reducing
co2 emissions
so we're pushed from above when we want
to be part of the supply chain and we're
also holding our suppliers accountable
for that because they have to report up
through us to do this there are a lot of
economic drivers for this but it's also
the right thing to do and it's
critically important for us because
we're in a global competition for talent
all the time
and the people entering the organization
have expectations you know they come out
of schools like this they have
expectations for corporate behaviors and
and if we can't meet those expectations
then they'll leave and go somewhere else
because well you may not admit to it
your generation is not loyal to the
companies you work for I got suckered
into loyalty and hurt me a pat but I'm
really happy to be part of a income so
if we can't continually demonstrate to
you that our company cares about the
future in material ways related to the
environment to the skillsets those sorts
of things we can't possibly succeed so
there are all sorts of issues that are
driving our behavior so in your position
do you do primarily focus on making
AECOM more sustainable or how you you
know work with your clients is more
sustainable or a division of both
actually a division of three things so
part of it is our internal operations
and reporting we report under the Global
Reporting Initiative a variety of other
things and we report on our corporate
social responsibility that all comes
under my
my umbrella I'm also the enterprise's
global Global talking-head
sustainability so our people around the
world invite me to come and meet their
clients or to conferences that are
important in their spheres to talk about
these issues and I also in part of a
number of what we call win teams trying
to figure out for a particular client
who's issued an RFP or is interested in
work how we can position ourselves
authentically to be their preferred
choice without having to go to the
lowest cost every single time and the
lowest cost issues some of them are
worried about that but most of them are
worried about value and how do we make
sustainability part of their value
proposition and my role is to help with
that so when you're exploring how to
bring about resource efficiencies and
your clients or internally are there's
some notorious barriers that are just
the most problematic and what approaches
have you have you found that are
successful well there there are more
barriers than easy pathways to
opportunity I'll put it that way one of
the barriers that you're all going to be
dealing with as you enter organizations
of various types is the conventional
wisdom that's embedded above you a lot
of people find it risky professionally
to think too much when they they've
gotten away with doing the same way over
and over and and it's they've never
gotten called on it so change is and the
inability or unwillingness to make
change happen fluidly is a big barrier
I often say that
conventional wisdom is the biggest
barrier to sustainability yeah you're
not challenging the status quo and
that's because nobody actually knows
what sustainability means and the other
big barrier to sustainability is really
an inappropriate amount of certainty
because if we're not learning all the
time through science and those sorts of
things and bringing that into the
conversation then we're going to be able
to be really good at solving the problem
just as a new one has emerged because
we'll be focusing on the past rather
than the future so that's a barrier one
of the barriers is also the financial
side of things many owners are still
convinced that being more sustainable is
means that the price of their project is
going to go up in this recent and
continuing economic circumstance the
notion that I'm going to invest in
sustainability just because it's the
right thing to do has been taken off the
table except for owner occupied spaces
or for people for whom it's critical to
their brand or their ideology or their
culture so our challenge is to help them
understand how they can actually again
be more financially successful doing
things differently and in my experience
the we haven't done a very good job of
bringing the finance people to the table
to figure out how to make the business
case for these things and you know
engineers I'm a planner by background
you know there's there's a saying that
to a hammer everything looks like a nail
to a planner everything looks like a
planning problem and to an engineer
everything looks like an engineering
problem and Finance goes on and on
figuring out how as you're doing your
problem identification you can get away
from those discipline-based
problem identification into something
broader which is necessary if if we're
right in thinking that this is about
complexity it's not about being green
then that's absolutely necessary so let
me shift gears slightly and ask you
might be a philosophical question what
do you think is the appropriate role of
the private sector and developing these
resilient communities adaptable
communities communities writ large and
the pace of some of the mega trends the
mounting environmental pressures that we
mentioned earlier I spent about 18 years
in government before that I ran NGOs and
I've been in the private sector since
then I think the private sector has the
as the key role in terms of the
efficiency of resource allocation if you
can create pricing schemes and that
really make resources cost what they
actually cost then I think we can go a
long way with policy direction solving
the problem you know there will be early
adopters on the private side and you
don't want to inhibit them from going
forward but there will be people who
dragged behind and you need a regulatory
environment in order to to bring them
along the NGOs are also critical because
there they tend to be the conscious
conscience of the of the whole thing but
all three sides tend to misunderstand
motives misunderstand the triggers those
sorts of things when I was at the
University of Washington
I and a guy from the business school
teaching in sustainability we had a
class and had some academic name of
course but the real name was where does
money come from and where does it go
because if you don't know that there's
no way you can actually create the
incentives in the levers necessary to
get the behaviors of all the the players
engaged I think we do a fantastic job
within our company and a number of our
competitors also do fantastic jobs in
trying to push the envelope when the
client pushes back we accommodate the
client and when we can get the
conversation about return on investment
right the client doesn't push back
nearly so far so that's the private
sector when you start thinking about the
role of multinational corporations to
what degree is an appropriate desirable
necessary for them to work with with
governments to craft legislation
policies regulation that that move in
this positive direction toward
sustainability well we we think that
it's critical that that the private
sector multinationals be engaged in this
many people are critical of that role
because the assumption is that we're
trying to cut a deal to exempt us from
doing the right thing
the reality is that governments will
eventually regulate it and won't really
know how to get the most out of us in
the regulatory discussing so if we're
not at the table talking to them about
okay if this these are our concerns
here's what our shareholders care about
here's what it means in terms of our
business and get clear about that then
you can actually come up with a
regulatory environment that again
induces better behavior and punishes bad
behavior
but the when they were you know and I've
done this in my career the planning
director and as a city manager make
assumptions about what's in the city's
interest without taking into account the
fact that if there's no wealth creation
going on the city is not successful
anymore so the private sector is wealth
is created and the Treasury prints the
money but wealth is created in the
private sector if we could find ways to
create that wealth reduce unemployment
increase investments in environmental
quality improve society through a
regulatory scheme that is broad rather
than narrow then I think we have a great
chance to make a huge amount of
difference I'm gonna be turning to the
audience in just a couple minutes so get
your questions together I just wanted to
follow up with you but it seems as
though you're you're pretty clear that
we can meet economic goals financial
goals at the same time as we're making
environmental improvement could you talk
to us a little bit about the the social
side the societal side societal benefit
and how you work that framework into
your your decisions the way that a-come
undertakes projects and and works with
its clients sure well we do it in a
variety of ways we have a major
initiative throughout the company and
corporate social responsibility working
with communities around the world for
instance in our space income is mostly
engineers we work with engineers Without
Borders to and allow people leave time
to go work around the world and solving
problems it's good for where they're
working and it's also really good for us
because if you work in a company like a
calm you almost never learn how to solve
problems without money engineers Without
Borders you learn how to solve problems
without money and
role of the community and long-term
maintenance I mean you can I've been all
over Africa parts of Asia and there's
huge investments in infrastructure that
are just worthless because the community
wasn't actually engaged in the new city
making they were never trained how to
operate it there were no spare parts all
that's what was done so we do that sort
of thing we also for instance working
with our clients we design hydroelectric
dams we work very closely on the
environmental side with the oil and gas
business and logistics and those sorts
of things every one of those requires a
large bunch of community engagement so
that the process of change does not
degrade quality of life and so that it
improves economic opportunity not
perfect by any stretch of the
imagination but it's a core to how we
approach problem solving with
infrastructure so there was one question
that I that I promised a student that I
would ask and she would like to know can
growth as we've seen in the past century
ever being sustainable
probably not I once wrote a paper that
got some coverage and it was entitled
Evo weasels and sustainable development
and the Devo was about I'm old so my
favorite band vivo which was about
devolution and so society was devolving
rather than evolving the weasels is
about all the people we pay to tell us
that's not our fault you know and the
sustainable development the issue there
was that the question can we sustain
ourselves is among the most banal
questions we can ask because
sustainability isn't that choice it's an
inevitability
we cannot exceed our range just like any
other species so the issue is whether we
achieve sustainability with some sense
of grace or we do it through systems
collapse and I think that the jury's
really out on how we're going to manage
this we see system human systems
collapsing around the world through
scarcity of resources
I mean Somalia is all about food
resources the Arab Spring was about the
price of bread and you know all these
things are are engaged in this and and
as I tell my staff I'm gonna do the best
I can but by the time it gets really
ugly if it does I'll be dead so it's up
to you actually to be humble as you go
forward in this because nobody knows the
right answer what we do need is a series
of best answers that are technically
feasible economically viable and
politically acceptable and moving that
way and tomorrow you may have a better
chance to make more progress but make
the progress you can today let's turn to
the audience I'm sure there's a quite a
number of good questions if we raise
your hand a microphone will will come to
you for the benefit of the recording if
you could start by stating your name and
affiliation before your question thanks
Gabriel with the forestry environmental
studies school so I have some questions
first of all I really appreciated that
you said nobody knows what
sustainability is I'm wondering if you
can elaborate more and how you relate to
it from that context and also I'm really
curious about your corporate culture and
how taking on sustainability has
impacted your culture if you could speak
to that and if there's any intentional
initiatives along that line and how you
measure it I relate to sustainability
again in this notion that
human society is in a struggle with
limits and also in its struggle with
limits it's producing large amounts of
waste that are going to make our lives
intolerable and it's about it's a it's
an existential question about us we're
irrelevant to the earth know the earth
is gonna do just fine it may be
different that sort of stuff so what are
we gonna do as humans who are struggling
to make sure that our children and their
children actually have a life for me
that's how I relate to it it's it I
don't think of it as a technical idea
you know certainly we need to improve
our techniques we need to improve our
science but I think sustainability is a
political choice about what we value and
whether we're going to continue or not
in our corporate culture sustainability
is one of the bedrocks I was hired to be
the chief sustainability officer by the
CEO with clear instructions that our
whole enterprise has to be built around
the notion that we manage complexity in
order to reduce waste increase
efficiency and improve human lives and
so given our position in the world and
that's that's what we're doing and it's
it's absolutely critical you know I get
I get a lot of queries I get to work
with the leading business leadership
around the world I'm invited in because
they know it's in critical for their
business in China if they're not making
every project more sustained sustained
of all we can't work in China anymore
because in China they recognize that
unless they reduce pollution and
increase energy efficiency that the
middle class is going to rise up and
challenge the party you know because the
party is only a 65 year experiment and
the history of China
so there are all sorts of things that
are going on in that background but for
us we don't think we can continue unless
we get sustainability not necessarily
right because no one knows it is but
push it hard on everything we do hi my
name is Hilary saber I'm a master
student here at FES and going back to
what you were saying earlier about the
importance of context when you're
working on infrastructure projects how
does a EECOM approach a new project in
terms of learning what the context is
for the area where you'll be working
do you go mostly through your client and
and I mean I'm that they provide you
with information about the community and
the stakeholders and that kind of thing
or does a comm go out into the community
and contact stakeholders like other
stakeholders independently of your
client and base and try and do sort of
like a broad research like information
gathering effort we do a little both
sometimes for instance if it's if it's a
national government client we don't go
and do separate due diligence from what
they say for some of our private sector
clients we do we we have an office of
risk management that is very broad
spectrum risk that we look at and
they'll go out and do the independent
research those sorts of things because
sometimes the we'll get information that
actually isn't useful and understanding
our risk
hi I'm Jim Goldwyn I'm with the School
of Management I was wondering if you can
talk about how you and your clients
communicate the work you do to sort of
the broader the consumers to the people
who are impacted by these projects and
especially in terms of the sustainable
aspects whether or not that's something
that your clients feel the need to
emphasize or if it's something they
don't really talk about thank you well
first of all almost always are
contractually bound to not speak on
behalf of our client or the project
that's that's their job we have
continuous conversation with our clients
and sometimes they ask us to help them
with their communication strategy we
have a big group that does community
involvement outreach in each of our
geographies around the world
so we'll get engaged that way but we
don't speak on behalf of our clients hi
thanks for being here my name is bendin
pearson I'm a PhD student here if yes
I'm early mentioned the dangers of
conventional following conventional
wisdom and the path dependency that
comes with that I'm just wondering some
would argue that large corporations and
institutions in the world are the very
agents who are successful to
perpetuating conventional wisdom so as a
large corporation what are some of the
processes internally or externally that
you have in place to prevent you know a
con from falling into the trap of
falling conventional wisdom we do it in
a variety of ways as you might imagine
but we have a lot of training
I spent Saturday and Friday and Saturday
and training for how we manage our
projects those sorts of things but we
have a chief innovation officer and our
chief innovation officer is responsible
to the CEO for not just driving
innovation down but pulling innovation
up this goes back to the notion that any
complex organization there will be
barriers to flow may be critically
interested because they're hearing from
clients about the changes that are
necessary as we do our exit interviews
we do exit interviews for almost every
one of our projects those sorts of
things what could have been better those
sorts of things what did they expect to
see that they didn't get from us and
then we're bringing in people from all
over the world coming out of schools not
of the quality of Yale of course but
from pretty good schools who have
learned things that nobody in our
organization has learned our challenge
is to to not do everything differently
every day but to capture the information
sets from the people like you who are in
the organization and start building a
knowledge base so that we can think
about problem-solving differently and I
have to say that like any major
organization as you point out it's a
daily struggle you know because we know
how to do things the way we've done them
before and there's some safety you know
and our clients know how people have
solved their problem before and they not
be they might think well I I just want
to do it the same way I don't want to be
on the leading edge and I particularly
don't want to be on the bleeding edge
because that's where cost overruns come
and oh that's really so it's a daily
challenge for us but we recognize
unless we get better at moving
innovation up and down that we won't be
successful compared to our competitors
just follow up on you mentioned about
new people coming into the company what
do you look for in your new hires
generally speaking well this might be a
particular interest to this group in the
technical disciplines or as we look for
technical competence but ever more
technical competence is not enough to
get you in our doors the the social
skills necessary to actually collaborate
around complicated problems are really
critical to us because we were betting
our future on integrated approaches to
problems so if we have people who are
extraordinarily talented who can't see
themselves as part of a team and and
feel like they have the right answer and
no one else can and therefore every bit
of dissonance is a dysfunctional we
can't actually move ahead
so it's this it's this ability to
communicate not just via emails but
actually to understand the needs of the
different people in the group how they
learn that sort of stuff so that that's
critical and one of the lessons I was
taught early and I'm not sure that I'm
managing it today but the one I was
taught that it is never the audience's
obligation to understand you it's always
the speaker's obligation to make him or
sell herself understood and we need
people who embody that notion because
even particularly in the highly
technical areas it's possible that we
can go before clients and have people
just assume that if they didn't get it
it's because they're not as smart as me
when our job is to make them successful
because we don't succeed unless our
clients are successful
that's great advice I think we have a
question right right over here much wool
email from F yes the aspect of maybe
communicating some of the
sustainability's philosophy to other
clients so say if you're trying to
engage with a client with potential
client who doesn't just doesn't get it
and who could at the same time maybe
benefit from some systemic change in the
company culture and structures would you
try to approach them in just maybe at a
very superficial level just to try to
get him into the door first well how
would you approach that really good
question
clients don't like to be told what they
don't know I think you'll find that
through your careers so it's our job to
make our clients successful in their
terms in the most sustainable way
possible it's not our job to tell them
they have to be sustainable so there
there will be huge opportunities through
the discussion and as I mentioned
earlier get changing the question set
and those sorts of things so that they
can see how being more sustainable
actually is great business or have
conversations with them about
recruitment and retention or safety and
you know productivity the rule of thumb
at least when I was in the business the
rule of thumb is that the cost of site
acquisition design construction and
maintenance of a building is 10% of the
lifecycle cost of that building and 90%
is the salaries being paid to the
employees working in that building and
through sustainability you can get a one
or two percent increase in productivity
over the life of the building than the
building's free so we have those kinds
of conversations with
you know and there's not good metrics on
that outside of the hospital industry
but the hospital industry is a great
proxy because they understand that the
right environmental conditions indoors
actually relate to the rates of healing
and if they can get people in the bed
make all the money at intake and then
get them out so they have a bed to fill
and make more money at intake that's
what they want to do so one of your big
challenges particularly on the design
side will be coming up with the metrics
that the financial community will accept
about how better design that our
buildings more environmental approaches
actually improves productivity because
that's that's the that's the gold
standard thank goodness please write
their name is Anna I'm from school of
management and you spoke about
communication with the client a lot I
was wondering if you noticed any
difference in your clients perception
when they come from a developed country
or developing country how do you deal
with those differences in perception in
the sustainability discussion and can
you give an example I am sure I'm where
you are not allowed maybe to say nice
but can you just get me a little bit
more particular and how you deal with
these differences thank you first of all
and I think every one of our offices the
majority of the people are from the
country that the office is in because it
doesn't work for us to have a bunch of
expats going in who have no
understanding whatsoever of cultural
issues you know I treat the example go
into an Arab country North America and
try to relax cross your legs and show
the soles of your feet you've offended
every single Arab in the room it's the
most vulgar thing you can do
and and we have to learn that kind of
stuff but it doesn't that's just trivial
compared to how decision understanding
culturally how decisions get made you
know in Japan you make a handshake
agreement with the leader of the
organization and everybody goes back to
make that happen in China you have to
enter at the bottom of the organization
and try to work your way up and figure
out whether the pathway is the right
pathway or the wrong pathway in in
Russia it's different and in the Africa
where we work it's different so we find
that diversity cultural diversity is a
key to our business opportunities in the
world whether developed or undeveloped
and so we we push really hard on all
aspects of diversity and that's how we
approach it because we know that you
know we're a North American corporation
a u.s. corporation if we're out there
trying to win work in China without
having Chinese leadership we know we
don't stand a chance and we have a lot
of good questions but I think we have
time for one more
it's Justin Linden Mayer a joint degree
with the school management in the school
forestry I'm always fascinated by how
sustainability is structured at
different organizations you as a chief
sustainability officer you know some
people may think of that as kind of
separate from traditional functional
roles versus organizations that don't
have sustainability as its own
functional role but is rather
incorporated into you know finance and
marketing and whatnot so given that at
AE comm you and presumably a team has
sustainability as your charge I'm
curious how you make sure that people in
the more traditional functional roles
also make decisions
with sustainability principles in mind
rather than trying to kind of do it
through the sustainability team
constantly well we we're structured I'm
a corporate officer in addition to being
the chief sustainability officer and
part of the the corporate team and I
work for the chief corporate officer so
there's a head of safety so does a head
of security so does the head of csr so
does a whole bunch of people and we
actually work in a cross-functional team
where we we define the problems that
need to be solved either being brought
to us or what we're trying to do
internationally and to make ourselves
more cohesive and make sure that
sustainability is an aspect so just a
brief example if I can we don't own any
of our own space we lease everything and
head of global real estate we're
consolidating space for a variety of
reasons but as part of that
consolidation I wake I work with her to
make sure all the new space has green
leases so that we can actually measure
our energy consumption and our water
consumption and our waste consumption
and we pay for it not part of the the
ground lease or they pay for it as a
separate line item so reducing it
becomes an issue of cost reduction which
increases the attention to it paid by
the people who are leading the offices
because if they're not reducing their
costs then finance is going to come and
visit them and and so there's a variety
of ways we do that
integrating it into the business is the
key objective for me so that hopefully
our culture becomes one where my role
isn't necessary
hopefully it remains necessary for a
little while but but if I a calm will
not be successful in the sustainability
space if it's always being put
from above it's got to be integrated
into how we view the world and it has to
be part of everything every decision we
make so art my job is to make sure that
I'm working with all the other people
who are working in similar space so that
there's a sustainability aspect and
everything they do and there's a safety
aspect and everything we doing in
sustainability and so in our last minute
carry well you have a tremendously
influential job and a tremendously
influential company what keeps you awake
at night well there are the rants in New
York what really keeps me awake at night
is that we're fighting the wrong fights
we keep trying on climate side in
particular we keep trying to convince
the doubters that they're wrong rather
than focusing on how to make people who
are willing to consider climate as an
issue how to help them become more
richer if we can help the people who
change and become wealthier and have a
competitive advantage over the deniers
then the market will lead the way but so
long as we're just in a pitched battle
in a religious battle over this and no
offense but science is a kind of
religion you know it's not purely
rational we're in this ideological
struggle over these ideas when nobody
knows the right answer and we can't make
any progress that way so that's what I
worry about is that we've abandoned the
notion of reason because it's easier to
just fight
please join me in thanking Gary for